über den historischen tag heute im
bundestag
[Musik]
sie wissen haben wir gestern entschieden
dass deutschland der ukraine waffen zur
verteidigung des landes liefern wird
aus dressur konnte es keine andere
antwort geben wenn uns gewählt eine
andere ist dann muss auch unsere politik
eine andere sein wir werden russland
isolieren
wirtschaftlich finanziell und politisch
deutliche worte heute im bundestag die
eine zeitenwende in der deutschen
politik bedeuten herzlich willkommen zu
einem weiteren zdf spezial
über die einschneidenden
regierungserklärung heute und ihre
folgen für deutschland bietet gleich
ausführlich berlin direkt doch bevor wir
zur theo koll abgeben blicken wir in die
ukraine wo der krieg auch am tag vier
weitergeht cornelia donath mit einem
überblick
kiews innenstadt soll sich bislang gegen
russische truppen verteidigen können in
kharkiv aber sehen die 1,4 millionen
einwohner von ihren fenstern aus die
russische armee ist bis ins zentrum der
stadt im nordosten der ukraine
vorgedrungen
raketen stecken in den straßen der
wohngebiete bilder vom ukrainischen
innenministerium veröffentlicht sollen
den morgen zeigen nach den heftigen
straßenkämpfen der nacht aber gefallen
sein archiv nicht versichert der
gouverneur auf telegramm die stadt sei
vollständig unter kontrolle der ukraine
verlassene panther ruinen der russen
sollen dies belegen aber es stimmt nicht
nachprüfbar
wieder hat die letzte nacht hier leben
gekostet über 100 sind verletzt wen es
nicht ganz so schwer getroffen hat
schützt sich mit den anderen im keller
des krankenhauses vor weiteren angriffen
all die menschen hier hatten nur eine
kleine operation so wie ich
wir können hier unter die anderen aber
nicht
in der nacht trafen russische geschosse
auch eine gaspipeline vor den toren der
stadt die explosionen weit zu sehen und
zu hören
und die kämpfe halten anschlüsse und
sirenen lassen die menschen rennen nur
weg von der straße
bei diesem einschlag soll ein mensch
gestorben seien drei wurden verletzt
direkt vor einem blutspendezentrum die
mitarbeiter verlegen die einrichtung
kurzerhand in den keller
angriffe auch in der umgebung von rajiv
gut 100 kilometer entfernt nach angaben
von ukrainischen rettungskräften sollen
hier mindestens vier menschen getötet
worden sein
im separatisten gebiet von donetsk wo
zerstörungen und krieg schon lange
alltag sind auch heute wieder trümmer
verzweiflung leid bombenteile sein auf
das haus seines nachbarn gefallen so
dieser mann nur anderthalb meter von
seinem zaun entfernt
alle zitterten ich bin rausgerannt und
wusste nicht was geschieht weil es noch
dunkel war
eine offensive der russischen armee
erwarten sie auch ein labor ist die
stadt liegt für das russische militär
strategisch günstig am fluss april von
hier aus so wird befürchtet könnten bald
die nächsten attacken kommen ukrainische
militärkonvois haben sich bereits auf
den weg gemacht um die stadt zu
verteidigen
basiert auf 30 kilometer südlich von
kiew stand schon gestern unter beschuss
auch letzte nacht haben wieder raketen
die stadt getroffen diesmal auch einen
öl terminal 1 feuerinferno die
bürgermeisterin spricht sich und ihren
einwohnern mut zu der feind will alles
zerstören aber er wird nichts erreichen
den ganzen tag lagen wir und lag unser
flughafen unter raketenbeschuss der
frist und nun geht es weiter aber alles
wird gut auch wenn es nicht leicht wird
hier oder in kiew mit gottes hilfe
werden wir das durchstehen
später folgt der entwarnung die
feuerwehr schaffte ist das feuer unter
kontrolle zu bringen auch verletzte gab
es scheinbar nicht so
weit der erste überblick mehr über die
lage in der ukraine gleich jetzt aber zu
der reaktion auf den russischen angriff
heute im bundestag die
regierungserklärung des bundeskanzlers
wurde zu einem historischen einschnitt
für deutschland mehr dazu jetzt in
berlin direkt mit theo koll wir melden
uns danach wieder thema vielen dank an
die piper mehrere hunderttausend
menschen haben heute in berlin gegen den
krieg demonstriert und fast zeitgleich
gab es im bundestag einen historischen
paukenschlag 100 milliarden euro für die
bundeswehr und ab sofort mehr als zwei
prozent des bruttoinlandsprodukts für
verteidigung wir besprechen das gleich
mit der bundesverteidigungsministerium
und mit dem mann der alles bezahlen soll
mit finanzminister lindner die welt
danach ist nicht mehr dieselbe wie die
welt davor dass meinte heute der
bundeskanzler mit blick auf die
russische invasion und wenn es noch
eines belegs bedurft hätte dann liefert
die in die heutige sondersitzung des
deutschen bundestags christiane hübscher
über einen denkwürdigen tag auf der
ehrentribüne begrüße ich den botschafter
der ukraine doktor andré melnik
diese denkwürdige sondersitzung des
bundestags beginnt mit einem nicht enden
wollenden applaus für mac er hatte
deutschland regelrecht um hilfe
angefleht in den letzten tagen den
bundeskanzler öffentlich kaltherzig und
stur genannt
eine minute und zwölf sekunden lang
erhebt sich das parlament für ihn
stellvertretend für alle 40 millionen
ukrainer nur die ard bleibt sitzen
olaf scholz wird dann in seiner
regierungserklärung versuchen eine
begründung zu geben für einen
persönlichen und politischen um schwenk
wie es ihn in nachkriegsdeutschland noch
nicht gegeben haben dürfte
erleben eine zeitenwende
und das bedeutet die welt danach
ist nicht mehr dieselbe wie die welt
davor
im kern geht es um die frage ob macht
das recht brechen darf ob wir es putin
gestatten die uhren zurückzudrehen in
die zeit der großmächte des neunzehnten
jahrhunderts oder ob wir die kraft
aufbringen kriegstreibern nikotin
grenzen zu setzen
scholz wirft dafür ein eisernes mantra
über bord die bundesregierung wird der
ukraine sofort waffen zur verteidigung
schicken und deutschland wird mehr viel
mehr in die eigene sicherheit
investieren etwas das die spd bisher
immer verhindert hat aber machen wir uns
nichts vor bessere ausrüstung modernes
einsatzgerät mehr personal das kostet
viel geld
wir werden dafür
ein sondervermögen bundeswehr einrichten
der bundeshaushalt 2022 wird dieses
sondervermögen einmalig mit 100
milliarden euro ausstatten die mittel
werden wir für notwendig
wir werden von nun an jahr für jahr mehr
als zwei prozent des
bruttoinlandsprodukts in unserer partei
zu investieren
für oppositionsführer märz ist die lage
schwierig scholz hat praktisch über
nacht alles abgeräumte wofür die union
ihn gerne kritisiert hätte der
ausschluss russlands von swift
waffenlieferungen wär et all das
unterstützen cdu und csu und so bleibt
märz nur der hinweis auf die belastung
der nächsten generation
sondervermögen ist nicht ein vermögen
sondern ein sondervermögen sind zunächst
einmal neue schulden und wie wir diese
neuen schulden aufnehmen und wie wir sie
dann möglicherweise in unserer
verfassung verankern das geht nicht
allein mit einer regierungserklärung am
sonntagmorgen zu machen der fdp
finanzminister kontert das sei der preis
der freiheit zahlbar sogar unter der
künftigen wieder einhaltung der
schuldenbremse lindner erinnert daran
wer 16 jahre lang das
verteidigungsministerium führte
friedrich merz wir werden nicht danach
fragen
wer die verantwortung für den zustand
der bundeswehr hat wir werden nicht mit
dem finger aufeinander zu zeigen
aber die investitionen in die bundeswehr
über friedrich merz die sollten sie
nicht führen mit der warnung von neuen
schulden das sind in wahrheit natürlich
kredite die wir aufnehmen in den
nächsten jahr aber in dieser welt lage
sind es zunächst und zumeist
investitionen in unsere freiheit auch
die grünen hatten noch im wahlprogramm
das zwei prozent ziel der nato abgelehnt
und waren immer gegen waffenlieferungen
aussenministerin berbalk verteidigt die
plötzliche kehrtwende vor wenigen wochen
noch habe ich hier in diesem jahr zum
thema waffenlieferungen gesagt dass man
seine außenpolitische
180 grad wendung im richtigen moment und
bei vollem bewusstsein treffen muss
jetzt ist so traurig es ist der moment
dafür
vizekanzler habeck spricht von einer
militärischen vergewaltigung der ukraine
durch russland die die grüne
friedenspartei zum umdenken führen allen
zweifeln zum trotz und ich achte ass
hoch eine position des unbedingten
pazifismus die sich sicherlich auch aus
dieser geschichte ableitet und sagt wir
können nicht weiter nächste schuld auf
uns lagen ich achte aber ich halte es
für falsch denn schuldig werden wir
trotzdem wir kommen mit sauberen händen
dann aus der sache nicht raus deswegen
ist die korrektur die die
bundesregierung gemacht hat also die
bereitschaft waffen zu liefern richtig
die linke besteht einen historischen
irrtum ein ja der aggressor heißt putin
doch die linksfraktion zieht andere
schlüsse daraus meine partei die linke
freue mich in aller deutlichkeit ein
dass wir die absichten der russischen
regierung falsch eingeschätzt haben bei
der frage was es jetzt allerdings zu tun
gilt sind wir in mehreren und pumpen
andere auf dessen und ich muss es
einfach in der deutlichkeit sagen dieses
hochrüsten diese militarisierung die
können und werden wir als linke nicht
mit auch die afg verurteilt den
russischen angriffskrieg sieht aber eine
mitschuld bei der nato und ist nicht
einverstanden mit höheren
militärausgaben herr scholz sie haben
heute leider die kalten krieg
reaktiviert mit ihrer rede das muss ich
so deutlich sagen
und wir müssen fragen welche sozialen
folgen hat ihre politik für die
deutschen bürger diese mission schon
jetzt überall mit steigenden preisen
leben lernt stichworte benzinpreise
heizkosten steigende inflation wollen
sie allen ernstes die bundesregierung
sein die wir soldaten in einen krieg
gegen russland schickt das leben wir
ebenso ab wie die lieferung von waffen
in kriegsgebiete es ist eine zäsur in
der deutschen politik es ist eine teure
zäsur so viel ist schon klar und es ist
putin der die ampel regierung zu diesem
dramatischen kurswechsel zwingt
das wort von der zeitenwende erlebt
aktuell eine inflation und dennoch ist
dieser historische superlativ berechtigt
jahrzehntealte politische grundfesten
werden über nacht verändert das ist eine
zeitenwende
ines trams zeigt wie wir außen und
verteidigungspolitik allzu lange
betrieben haben und was sich wie
verändert und verändern muss
der krieg ist zurück in europa die armee
des russischen präsidenten fällt in der
ukraine ein er will grenzen verschieben
ist bereit bis zum äußersten zu gehen
wäre das zu verhindern gewesen durch
eine härtere politik des westens
deutschlands der ukrainische botschafter
in berlin sieht sein land als opfer
einer episch und politik
die ukraine fühlen sich als ein
opferlamm
und als quasi eine folge von von von
dieser beschwichtigungspolitik
deutschlands in den letzten jahren auch
in den letzten monaten vielleicht und
das macht meine landsleute das macht
auch nicht persönlich wütend dialog hieß
bislang der deutsche ansatz man sah sich
in der vermittlerrolle wandel durch
handel
ein anderer glaubenssatz putin ein
partner kein aggressor daran änderten
auch seine luftangriffe auf georgien
nichts auch nicht die annexion der krim
hinweise wurden überhört ein russland
das nicht so sein wollte wie wir schwer
vorstellbar ich glaube schon dass die
deutsche politik die veränderung in der
welt nicht ganz mitbekommen hat in den
letzten jahren sogar jahrzehnten und
häufig in deutschland der fall ist dass
man die politik in die internationale
politik sender ihr betrachtet
vermittlungsversuche bis zum bitteren
ende putin verhöhnt alle besucher am
langen tisch mit dieser woche ist klar
die deutsche russland politik ist
gescheitert putin hat die
verhandlungsbereitschaft von uns
ausgenutzt und hat gesehen dass dahinter
weder die absicht ist dies militärisch
zu unterfüttern noch die bereitschaft
diplomatie und härte eindeutig zu zeigen
die deutsche außenpolitik am
scheidepunkt ratlos eine härtere gangart
bislang hat man sie vermieden wollte
ungern in unpopuläre dinge wie militär
investieren und abschreckung wollte
niemanden verprellen nun muss man sich
neu aufstellen
das heißt nicht dass man werte vergessen
soll aber es wird wesentlich mehr darauf
ankommen auch mit härte die westlichen
demokratischen interessen zu verteidigen
und ich glaube das müssen wir es wieder
neu lernen denn das haben wir verlernt
einmal aus guten gründen weil
deutschland mal in seiner geschichte
vieles falsch gemacht hat aber ein
bisschen auch weil es halt bequem war
und diese zeit ist zu ende
eine neue glaubwürdige außenpolitik klar
scheint
verteidigungsfähigkeit gehört dazu
ministerin lamprecht empfängt 350
zusätzliche soldaten in litauen es gilt
die ostflanke zu stärken wir stehen hier
wachsam und wehrhaft
ganz so ist es nicht die bundeswehr muss
sich strecken die aktuellen wünsche der
nato zu erfüllen drei zusätzliche
eurofighter nach rumänien eine korvette
eine kompanie in die slowakei noch immer
hat man die truppe nicht von
auslandseinsätzen umgestellt auf bündnis
und landesverteidigung das tut nun aber
nur wenn es um den sozusagen luftabwehr
gürtel geht wenn es aber gleichzeitig um
bodentruppen geht um unsere eurofighter
um unsere schiffe dann wissen wir genau
schauen wo haben wir was verfügbar es
ist nicht mehr alles selbstverständlich
da und diese mangelverwaltung die macht
uns natürlich nahezu wahnsinnig
tagtäglich heute verspricht kanzler
scholz der bundeswehr 100 milliarden
euro extra doch es wird dauern bis die
in der truppe ihre wirkung zeigen und
die mentalität in der außenpolitik muss
sich ändern wenn wir das nicht
verknüpfen mit einer realpolitischen
sicht auf die internationalen
beziehungen damit das alles nichts
bringen also jetzt mehr geld der
bundeswehr zu geben wird nichts bringen
wenn man sozusagen mentalitätsmäßig
nicht realisiert dass diese streitkräfte
ein instrument deutscher außenpolitik
sind mit deren einsatz waren auch drohen
kann der präsident von litauen ist nach
berlin gekommen für ein gespräch mit dem
kanzler stippvisite bei demonstranten
vor der russischen botschaft
er befürchte putin wird auch nach
anderen osteuropäischen ländern greifen
er will unterstützung und beobachtet
eine änderung im deutschen denken
einige augen wurden geöffnet
noch vor zwei drei monaten war es
manchmal recht kompliziert über russland
zu reden so viele vorbehalte und
tradition doch jetzt beginnt jeder zu
verstehen was passiert
waffenlieferungen sind nun möglich genau
wie russlands ausschluss aus dem
internationalen
zahlungssystem eine zeitenwende in der
deutschen außenpolitik deutet sich an
putins brutalität ließ keine andere wahl
und im studio begrüße ich christine
lambrecht die
bundesverteidigungsministerium die nicht
einmal 100 tage im amt ist und schon mit
einem krieg in unserer nachbarschaft zu
tun hatten habt euch erlauben sie mir
eine persönliche frage zu beginn sie
sind gelernte rechtsanwältin sie waren
justiz und verbraucherschutz ministerin
und jetzt haben sie mit krieg zu tun
putin hat sogar heute seine
atomstreitkräfte alarmiert haben sie
jemals mehr verantwortung gefühlt das
ist schon eine besondere aufgabe im
verteidigungsministerium weil man
natürlich die verantwortung für so viele
soldatinnen und soldaten hat das spürt
man jeden tag aber darüber hinaus auch
anforderungen an einen gestellt werden
die ebenfalls immer mit menschen zu tun
haben und das ist es was so
herausfordernd ist putin hat heute wir
haben gerade gesagt seine
atomstreitkräfte
alarmiert was wissen sie darüber es ist
eine weitere stufe die er geht und wir
haben den eindruck dass das auch damit
was zu tun hat das in seinem großmacht
war der schnelle marsch durch die
ukraine gestoppt wurde durch mutiges
durch engagierte einschreiten und
verteidigen der ukraine halten sie es
für drohgebärde oder für ernsthafte
ernsthafte gefahr wir sind gut beraten
putin und seine äußerungen sehr ernst zu
nehmen und nicht abzutun denn er hat
gezeigt dass er auf der einen seite
truppenabzug versprochen hat und dann
knall hat einen brutalen angriffskrieg
durchgezogen hat deswegen sehr wachsam
sehr wachsam seine äußerungen beobachten
und auch das was jetzt daraus geschichte
leitungen durch aufklärung auch ganz
dauerhaft und sehr intensiv über die spd
fraktionsvorsitzender hat ja heute
gesagt es könne durchaus sein dass putin
auch noch andere länder überfällt wissen
sie da konkret ist wir haben keine
konkreten hinweise darauf dass das
geplant ist aber ich sage es nochmal
jemand der bereit ist
zusagen zu brechen völkerrecht mit füßen
zu treten und einem brutalen angriffs
krieg zu starten da müssen wir sehr
wachsam sein was die nächsten schritte
sein können und bekommen sie einen
sonder betrag von 100 milliarden euro
sie haben heute im bundestag selber
applaudiert als der kanzler ist
verkündet hat aber die ausrüstung der
bundeswehr zu verbessern ist ja
bekanntermaßen ein sehr langwieriger
langsamer prozess wie wollen sie das
überbrücken wir haben ganz viele große
projekte die jetzt an den start gehen
können weil ich eben auch die
finanzielle rückendeckung dann habe da
ist vieles nicht entschieden worden weil
man darauf gewartet hat das geht jetzt
das sind zwar lange abläufe aber es geht
aber wir müssen dann eben auch in der
struktur veränderungen vornehmen
beispielsweise beim vergaberecht dass
aufträge auch schneller vergeben werden
können also das ist ein konkreter machen
also meldet viele ihrer vorgänger sind
ja daran gescheitert bei dieser
beschaffung ja aber wir haben jetzt
schon die möglichkeit dass dann wenn es
um ausrüstung für den einsatz geht das
dann das vergaberecht eingeschränkt ist
und nicht mehr so groß ausgeschrieben
werden muss und das möchte ich jetzt
ebenfalls für die landes- und
bündnisverteidigung einführen habe
darüber mit meinem kollegen
justizminister auch gesprochen da müssen
wir schnell sein damit wir eben solche
projekte auch durchführen können und
nicht auf die lange bank schieben ist
das eigentlich ein fehler dass wir die
zahl der soldaten so drastisch reduziert
haben brauchen wir wieder eine
wehrpflicht was wir brauchen sind vor
allen dingen gut ausgebildete und gut
ausgerüstete soldatinnen und soldaten
gut ausgebildet sind sie aber an der
ausrüstung mangelt ist und wenn wir
menschen in den einsatz schicken dann
müssen sie das auch mitbekommen dann
darf es nicht daran haben dass man mit
material zu tun hat dass man vorher noch
nicht indem man vorher noch nicht üben
konnte hier darum geht es ja die antwort
verstehe ich aber die frage war eine
andere brauchen wir wieder die wirklich
ich glaube es ist momentan nicht die
zeit diese entscheidung zu beraten oder
womöglich gar zu treffen da wären viele
rechtliche fragen auch damit zu klären
würden sie es wollen ich persönlich in
der aktuellen situation nein ich glaube
dass es wirklich etwas was man wenn dann
auf breitere füße vielleicht ein
allgemeines engagement für diesen staat
aber als reine wehrpflicht würde ich
momentan nicht unterstützt wir haben ja
unsere verteidigung im prinzip
umgestellt von dieser nacht 89 von
dieser massiven land armee und
verteidigung auf beispielsweise
internationale einsätze zeigt das
russische vorgehen dass wir wieder eine
neuausrichtung brauchen wir brauchen
sowohl das eine als auch das andere war
gerade im internationalen missionen sind
wir ein ganz wichtiger partner weil wir
ganz besondere fähigkeiten auch
mitbringen aber was wir jetzt sehen ist
eben dass wir dann eben die landes- und
bündnisverteidigung nicht
vernachlässigen dürfen damit muss
schluss sein deswegen bin ich kanzler
scholz auch sehr dankbar dass er diese
ganz klare aussage getroffen hat und
seine freiheit unsere demokratie und
diese auch zu verteidigen das muss uns
etwas wert sein ganz salopp formuliert
wann sehen sie denn land das hier so
weit sind mit der bundeswehr wir können
entscheidungen sehr schnell treffen die
dann auch ganz schnell bei den
soldatinnen soldaten ankommen aber bei
großen rüstungsprojekten
haben wir natürlich auch die
entsprechenden zeitabläufe aber jetzt
kann es los gehen jetzt können die
entscheidungen getroffen werden weil
eben auch die finanzielle unterlegung
gewährleistet ist frau ministerin ich
danke ihnen sehr für das gespräch
am ende stand berlin ganz alleine da in
seiner ablehnung von swift sanktionen
und hat dann gestern abend die kurve
gekriegt und sich einer abgespeckten
version angeschlossen auch um der
eigenen wirtschaft nicht zu sehr zu
schaden ausgeschlossen werden jetzt nur
einige russische banken angeblich können
so die energielieferungen weiterhin
bezahlt werden heike slansky hat sich
das thema sanktionen angesehen was sie
bringen und was nicht und welchen preis
sind wir bereit zu zahlen
was kann putin stoppen alle
diplomatischen auf wartungen des westens
ohne annäherung die gefahr schweißt die
verbündeten zusammen europa und nato
partner entschlossen wie lange nicht
mehr sie drohen putin unverhohlen mit
wirtschaftlichen konsequenzen das werden
sehr weitreichende sehr harte sanktion
sein scholz droht putin bleibt
unbeeindruckt und greift an
die ökonomische abschreckung gescheitert
der westen im zugzwang doch scholz
zögert am donnerstag noch will er
schärfere massnahmen aufbehalten für
eine situation wo das notwendig ist auch
noch andere dinge zu tun die
beschworene einigkeit bekommt risse
deutschland bremst will das
internationale finanzsystem swift nicht
anfassen gestern die kehrtwende scholz
beugt sich dem druck der eu und der usa
wenn wir nicht bereit sind einen preis
zu zahlen
für die verteidigung der europäischen
friedensordnung für ein europa was sich
auf freiheit auf unabhängigkeit
souveränität
selbstbestimmungsrecht aller nationen
gründet dann werden wir
autoritäre regimes die zu gewalt bereit
sind nicht abschrecken können wenn es
uns nicht wehtut tut es putin erst recht
nicht wie
deutschland opfert nach jahrelangem
drängen von europäern und amerikanern
die umstrittene gas pipeline aus
russland nord stream zwei vertraglich
besiegelt kurz nach der
völkerrechtswidrigen annexion der krim
auch damals wurden sanktionen verhängt
trotzdem macht deutschland weiter
lukrative geschäfte mit dem aggressor
schafft eine abhängigkeit die sich nun
rächt die architekten der alten
russlandpolitik gestehen fehler ein ich
glaube es gilt für öl und gas
grundsätzlich auch insgesamt beim handel
wir müssen uns sehr viel stärker
diversifizieren wir dürfen uns nicht von
ländern abhängig machen die an ihrer
spitze diktatoren autoritäre regime
haben denn da begeben wir uns in eine
abhängigkeit
putin hat sich an sanktionen des westens
gewöhnt und vorbereitet er hat polster
geschaffen historisch hohe
währungsreserven
640 milliarden dollar in der kriegskasse
kaum staatsverschuldung seine yacht
lässt er bevor die neuen sanktionen
gegen ihn persönlich greifen aus einem
deutschen hafen verlegen egal was jetzt
noch kommt putin lässt sich nicht
aufhalten meinen experten
für die russische führung für den
präsidentenposten spielen dieser kosten
eine untergeordnete rolle die wurden
schon längst einkalkuliert also
mittlerweile sieht präsident position
alles sei eine historische mission
russland und die ukraine oder zumindest
den russischsprachigen teil der ukraine
wieder zu vereinigen egal was es kostet
deswegen werden diese sanktionen wie
gesagt
nicht davon abhalten mit aller härte
gegen putin doch die schärfsten
maßnahmen den gas oder öl hahn
abzudrehen stehen nicht zur diskussion
tatsächlich treffen putin ein gasstopp
am härtesten mittelfristig minus 2,9
prozent vom bruttoinlandsprodukt für
deutschland wäre der schaden insgesamt
gering
wir sollten uns nicht der illusion
hingeben dass wenn wir jetzt aufhören
würden energieträger aus russland zu
importieren dort sofort zum rückzug
geblasen würde das würde mit sicherheit
nicht eintreten aber wir würden die
russische wirtschaft auf dauer deutlich
schwächen und am ende ist die
militärische
potenz auch immer eine frage der
dahinterstehenden wirtschaftskraft also
wenn man sehr langfristig agieren möchte
dann können auch diese kurzfristig
schmerzhaften schritte sehr sinnvoll
sein
die guten geschäfte mit einem diktator
für die deutsche wirtschaft brechen
bittere zeiten an das volumen von
importen und exporten zwischen
deutschland und russland ist über die
vergangenen zwei jahre
34 prozent gestiegen wir haben
jahrzehntelang der ost-ausschuss 70
jahre lang unseres brückenbauer
verstanden zwischen deutschland und den
ländern osteuropas und mit einem großen
teil osteuropas nämlich mit russland
scheint das jetzt für die nächste zeit
erst mal vorbei zu sein was bringt putin
zum umdenken
das einstehen für werte gegen
wirtschaftliche interessen sanktionen
als letztes politisches
machtmittel ein hoher preis den auch der
westen zu entrichten hat
und bei uns ist jetzt der mann der viele
dieser dramatischen veränderung bezahlen
soll oder bezahlen muss guten abend
christian guten abend herr kolbe zahlen
müssen aber die bürgerinnen und bürger
ich verwalte nur möglichst
verantwortungsbewusst deren geld darum
soll es jetzt geht die sanktionen der
finanzminister inklusive swift sollen
putin ja hart treffen aber sie treffen
natürlich auch uns mit welchen
auswirkungen rechnen sie das ist noch
offen die volkswirtschaftliche
auswirkung
insgesamt kann überschaubar sein weil
das bilaterale handelsvolumen so groß
nicht ist deutschland ist eine
exportnation die in viele teile der welt
waren liefert die große frage ist dies
mit der rohstoffversorgung weitergeht
gas öl kohle das war und ist ja auch der
grund warum die bundesregierung sehr
sorgfältig die finanziellen sanktionen
vorbereitet hat das heißt sie gehen
davon aus die werden die werden weiter
fließen diese energie mindestens haben
wir keinen vorwand geliefert dass die
russische seite diese lieferungen
einstellt das war ja kern der diskussion
um swift wir wollen russland isolieren
wir wollen seine banken isolieren wir
wollen die oligarchen treffen wir wollen
die wirtschaft schwächen wir wollen
putin aber keinen vorwand liefern
rohstofflieferungen einzuschränken oder
zu stoppen weil wir nicht mehr bezahlen
nicht mehr bezahlen können aber sollte
man das nicht
also in genau da stoppen
wir müssen uns ja auf eine sehr lange
phase einstellen wir brauchen also
durchhaltefähigkeit wichtig für unsere
durchhaltefähigkeit ist dass wir unsere
strategische position gegenüber putin
nicht selbst schwächen selbst wir können
es uns gar nicht erlauben wir haben
große finanzielle reserven wir werden
uns in der energieversorgung
unabhängiger auf stern stand jetzt
könnte es aber taktische vorteile bei
putin geben und aus diesem grund haben
wir diesen weg bei den finanziellen
sanktionen bei swift gewählt übrigens in
großer übereinstimmung mit unseren
partnern und verbündeten anders als der
beitrag angedeutet hat nochmal jetzt zum
verständnis das heißt sie haben jetzt
mit diesem reduzierten swiss verfahren
wege von denen sie wissen damit können
sie die energie dieser einkaufen wollen
in russland auch bezahlen ja es werden
in der ganzen breite finanzielle
transaktion unterbunden banken werden
wie man sagt gelistet die russische
notenbank wird empfindlich getroffen
werden aber für einzelne weniger
manuelle
transaktionen bleiben möglichkeiten
offen eben vor allen dingen für
rohstofflieferungen schauen wir jetzt
mal auf die bundeswehr und diese
historische ankündigung heute 100
milliarden sogenanntes sondervermögen
für die bundeswehr und jährlich über
zwei prozent des
bruttoinlandsproduktes woher kommt das
geld
es war auch ne hin geplant die
bundeswehr besser zu finanzieren
mein vorschlag wäre gewesen die
finanzierung der bundeswehr in jedem
jahr oberhalb von 50 milliarden euro
abzusichern
jetzt ist allerdings die sicherheitslage
noch einmal eine andere und wir müssen
ungleich andere anstrengungen deshalb
unternehmen und aus diesem grund haben
wir in den letzten tagen kanzleramt und
mein ministerium diesen plan entwickelt
für grosse rüstungsvorhaben für
den ausgleich dessen was über zehn jahre
und länger nicht investiert worden ist
schaffen wir jetzt an einmalige
sondervermögen von 100 milliarden euro
im grundgesetz abgesichert das wird
nicht für irgendetwas anderes verwendet
sondern nur für die bündnisfähig müssen
diese 100 milliarden dann in die zwei
prozent die sie erreichen wollen dass
haushalt ja
interessant dazu kommen schutzmaßnahmen
für firmen die von den sanktionen
betroffen sein werden mit wir rechnen
sie denn da hier muss man genau schauen
was ist die
volkswirtschaftliche größenordnung über
die wir an schaden sprechen es handelt
sich nicht um eine pandemie sondern es
ist an auch unternehmerisches risiko und
deshalb bedauere ich sagen zu müssen
es wird nicht möglich sein dass der
staat alle finanziellen folgen der
sanktionen und der spannung mit russland
übernimmt gar kompensiert sondern es
wird nur möglich sein
für einzelne bereiche oder für folgen
die die inflation vorsorge zu treffen
aber eine einzel entschädigung das ist
finanziell nicht darstellt der kanzler
hat ja heute sehr vieles garantiert
ausreichende finanzierung der bundeswehr
finanzierung der energiewende entlastung
der bürger was heißt denn das für die
schuldenbremse hat man halt wieder ab
dem nächsten jahr wird die
schuldenbremse eingehalten
ausgerechnet die spd treibt den
verteidigungsetat hier jetzt in neue
höhen und die fdp auch nicht wirklich
typisch für die fdp verschuldet das jahr
mit weiteren 100 milliarden euro für
verteidigungsausgaben ist das im grunde
die alte politische lehre nur die
parteien die das nicht wirklich
betreiben würden können dass dann
politisch durchsetzen
für die spd muss die sozialdemokratie
sprechen für die fdp kann ich sagen dass
wir die schuldenbremse im nächsten jahr
einhalten wir werden auch keine
steuererhöhungen vornehmen das sind die
beiden leitplanken die wir zugesagt
haben innerhalb dieser leitplanken
bewegen wir uns und müssen schwerpunkte
setzen das sind auch harte
verteilungsfragen die wir darstellen
müssen aber wir müssen beide ziele
einhalten sowohl die schuldenbremse als
auch den verzicht auf steuererhöhungen
es wurde im beitrag der eben auch gesagt
wir können sowohl unsere
verteidigungsfähigkeit als auch unsere
wirtschaftliche stabilität nur erhalten
wenn wir gesunde betriebe gesundes
handwerk wettbewerbsfähige industrie
haben und zugleich dürfen wir uns nicht
auf dauer in die abhängigkeit der
staatsverschuldung geben aus diesem
grund schuldenbremse und verzicht auf
steuererhöhungen das steht kurzer
schlusssatz von ihnen und der die der
krieg ist im grunde ein turbo jetzt für
die erneuerbaren energien die haben sie
ja als freiheits energien bezeichnet ja
da können und da müssen wir mehr tun wir
müssen die frage der
versorgungssicherheit neu klären dazu
gehört zum einen uns zu öffnen für
andere quellen des imports wasserstoff
synthetische flüssig kraftstoffe auch
flüssiggas auf der anderen seite müssen
wir die kapazitäten von erneuerbaren im
inland ausbauen herr minister herzlichen
dank für das gespräch danke ihnen herr
kohl
das war berlin direkt an einem tag
tiefer politischer zäsuren die
jahrzehntealte politische grundfesten
verändern und damit zurück zu anti
pieper und dem zdf spezial vielen dank
theo koll er wirklich ein
ereignisreicher tag heute mit einem
kurswechsel in der deutschen politik und
friedensverhandlungen zwischen der
ukraine und russland doch noch wird
gekämpft gert anhalt mit allem wichtigen
aus der ukraine
wenn bürger sich verabreden um gemeinsam
benzinbomben herzustellen dann ist ein
neues stadium des schreckens erreicht
nutzt alles was ihr zur hand habt um die
angreifer zu stoppen diese losung gab
die armee aus und das schon bevor eine
weitere nacht mit massiven attacken auf
die hauptstadt begann mit
leuchtspurgeschossen und kanonendonner
bis dann gegen 1 uhr der feuerschein am
südwestlichen nachthimmel die explosion
des öl terminals von vassiliki van
zeigte über 30 kilometer vor kiew
liebe mitbürger sie alle sehen das feuer
das kommt von unseren öl depot der feind
will alles zerstören aber er wird nichts
erreichen den ganzen tag lagen bier und
lag unser flughafen unter
raketenbeschuss und nun geht es weiter
aber alles wird gut auch wenn es nicht
leicht wird mit gottes hilfe werden wir
das durchstehen
nach dem ersten schrecken meldete sich
bald der katastrophenschutz und gab
entwarnung
wir haben das feuer innerhalb der anlage
gehalten es dient sich nicht aus und es
besteht keine gefahr für die bevölkerung
die gefahr freilich bestand für die
feuerwehrleute die sich dem entferner
entgegenstellten aber scheinbar wurde
niemand verletzt
gespenstische ruhe dagegen in den
straßen kiews über dass die regierung
eine ausgangssperre verhängt hat die
noch bis montag in kraft ist jeden der
draußen aufgegriffen wird betrachten wir
als feindlichen agenten lautet die
ansage und so verschanzten sich die
bürger in ihren wohnungen oder
verbrachten eine weitere nacht begleitet
vom geheul der sirenen im
luftschutzbunker oder in den wartezonen
der u-bahn von
freiwilligen mit dem nötigsten versorgt
und verpflegt und schöpften vielleicht
ein wenig kraft aus der gemeinschaft in
die ihre not sie gezwungen hat
die stimmung hier im bomben keller ist
gefasst es gibt viel menschliche wärme
und wir helfen einander
alles scheint nun mehr oder weniger
unter kontrolle wir sind auf einem guten
weg unsere soldaten haben die sache in
der hand
selbst das ukrainische fernsehen hat
studio und redaktionsräume verlassen und
sendet die nachrichten aus der
tiefgarage
weil es leider wieder fliegeralarm liebt
müssen wir uns von diesem ort melden
erklären die moderatoren aber viel
hoffnungsvolles haben sie nichts zu
berichten die kämpfe gehen im ganzen
land weiter und als der vierte kriegstag
über den menschenleeren straßen erwachte
und am fernen horizont die dunkle
rauchsäulen von den angriffen der nacht
erzählten meldete sich der bruder des
bürgermeisters mit einem eindringlichen
hilferuf
ich bin wladimir klitschko und ich
appelliere an die ganze welt diesen
krieg den russland angefangen hat zu
beenden
zivilisten werden von raketen getötet
oder von spezialeinheiten ermordet und
das mitten in europa wir sind auf dem
weg in eine humanitäre katastrophe
sie müssen die russische aggression
jetzt mit allen mitteln stoppen schon in
einer stunde oder morgen kann es zu spät
sein zögern sie nicht und stoppen sie
die russische aggression stoppen
aber wie in den sozialen netzwerken
kursieren dramatische aufnahmen von
mutmaßlichen ukrainischen bürgern die
russische panzerkolonnen zum stillstand
bringen wenigstens vorübergehend und
unter größter gefahr
wo sie entstanden und ob sie echt sind
niemand kann das sagen immer wieder ist
auch von jungen russischen gefangenen
und des härteren die rede die angeblich
nichts vom krieg wissen und denen
erzählt wurde sie zögen ins manöver und
dann wieder bilder einer
überwachungskamera
die russische soldaten beim plündern
eines ladengeschäfts zeigen sollen auch
dies ohne nachweis und ohne ortsangabe
militärkolonnen anscheinend russische
bewegen sich durch wohnsiedlungen diese
aufnahmen sollen aus charkiw stammen in
dessen zentrum sich die russen berichten
zufolge heute straßenkämpfe mit den
verteidigern lieferten
ob diese aufnahmen dann das ergebnis
dieser konfrontationen zeigen ist
wiederum kaum verlässlich zu ermitteln
charkiw sei aber wieder vollständig
unter ukrainischer kontrolle ließ
schließlich der gouverneur der region
verlauten jedoch gelang es den
angreifern offenbar in der nacht eine
gas pipeline in der nähe in die luft zu
jagen und während es weiterhin jede
verantwortung für zivile opfer und
schäden zurückweist meldet sich moskau
mit einer weiteren erfolgreichen
zwischenbilanz
insgesamt haben wir jetzt
975 objekte der militärischen
infrastruktur der ukraine getroffen
darunter 23 befehlszentrum und 48
radarstation
31 luftabwehrstellungen hinzu kommen
acht abgeschossene flugzeuge sieben
hubschrauber
223 panzer und
143 lkw
diese zahlen sind ebenso wenig zu
überprüfen wie die twitter bilder der
ukrainischen milizen die ihrem gegner
deftige flüche und üble verwünschungen
entgegenschleudern oder das video des
ukrainischen militärs das den
drohnenangriff auf einen russischen
konvoi zeigen soll russland verlor
sokhiev bereits 146 panzer 27 flugzeuge
und 26 hubschrauber sowie
4300 soldaten präsident see lenski
nachdem er dem westen und auch
deutschland für die militärische hilfe
dankte verurteilte in seiner jüngsten
ansprache die angreifer als
kriegsverbrecher
ihre beteuerungen keine zivilen ziele
anzugreifen sind lügen von der ersten
stunde an haben sie bewusst auf
zivilisten und alle einrichtungen
unseres alltags ins visier genommen
kraftwerke krankenhäuser kindergärten
und wohnungen all das wird jeden tag
beschossen
und während auf allen offiziellen und
inoffiziellen kanälen die
anschuldigungen und appelle
lügenpropaganda
hilferufe und beleidigungen hin und
herfliegen rüstet sich die ukrainische
hauptstadt für die nächste kriegs nacht
und vielleicht für den nächsten
russischen raketen regen
ja wir wollen auch heute noch mal mit
dem ehemaligen nato general egon ramms
sprechen guten abend
herr
ramis besonders unter beschuss sind wolf
im osten und die hauptstadt kiew wie
sehen sie die militärische lage moment
als zunächst mal der bericht gerade von
ihrem korrespondenten oder in dem
bericht war sehr gut weil er die
verschiedenen hinweise gegeben hat auf
die tatsache dass die ganzen meldungen
die dort zurzeit eingehen schwer
einzuschätzen sind
meine persönliche einschätzung jetzt
aufgrund der nachrichten die ich heute
verfolgt habe er informationen aus
verschiedenen quellen ist das markiert
zwar noch in den außenbezirken gekämpft
wird das offensichtlich die ukrainischen
streitkräfte weiter sich auf kiew
konzentrieren was charkiw angeht sie das
so aus als wenn tragt ihr folgte in
großen teilen in der hand der russen
gewesen wäre das ist das was ich im
augenblick schließt aus den aussagen
sowohl der bürgermeisterin als auch das
größte jung welche bedeutung hat es dass
russland seine atomstreitkräfte in
erhöhte alarmbereitschaft versetzt hat
aber das ist ein thema welches mir große
sorgen bereitet einfach große sorgen
bereitet aus dem grunde weil ich den
einsatz von atomstreitkräfte denn der
jetzt in situation nicht sehe und ich
bringe das auch nicht in zusammenhang
mit der aktion mit der situation der
ukraine und das richtet sich
offensichtlich als eine drohgebärde
gegen die nato wegen der
truppenverstärkung an der ostflanke
danach in der ukraine geben gibt dass
bilder von bürgern die molotow-cocktails
basteln oder straßenschilder abbauen
kann das bei der abwehr von solch einem
massiven truppenaufmarsch wirklich
helfen
oder das wird mit sicherheit oder werden
mit sicherheit keine
kriegsentscheidenden ereignisse werden
trotzdem ist in kleinigkeiten die die
bürger der ukraine dort durchführen mit
molotow-cocktails kann man panzer
zerstören wenn man sie dann mit diesen
flaschen trifft der wichtige punkt den
ich sie ist eigentlich ein anderer das
ist der punkt die tatsache dass
offensichtlich die ukrainischen bürger
mit einer relativ hohen intensität und
sich an diesen gefechten beteiligen
wollen und aufgrund dieser tatsache
schwierig den schluss daraus dass die
ukrainischen bürger wie die ukrainische
streitkräfte auch diese
partie nur bei ihnen klingelt aber noch
eine frage von dem was sie mit verkommen
reagieren denn die russischen soldaten
also das mit den russischen soldaten das
für mich im augenblick eine relativ
große unbekannte ich bin überrascht
gewesen zu hören dass russische soldaten
und das ist in meinen augen auch
bestätigt offensichtlich nicht gewusst
haben dass sie in der ukraine sind für
einen krieg um für einen angriff gegen
die ukraine sondern dass sie informiert
worden sind dahingehend dass es sich um
eine übung handelt
wenn das so ist und wenn sich das
bestätigt in den nächsten tagen dann
würde das bedeuten dass russland
gegenüber seinen soldaten eine
ausgesprochen mangelhafte
informationspolitik betreibt und damit
ist auch ein fragezeichen zu setzen dann
die motivation dieser sogar an der
informationspolitik vielen dank egon
ramms gerne herzlichen dank ja und in
der ukraine ist für uns katrin eigendorf
circa 200 kilometer südlich von kiew mit
welcher hoffnung wird denn auf die
friedensverhandlungen geschaut zwischen
der ukraine und russland
ja die leute mit denen wir hier heute
gesprochen haben sind doch alle relativ
skeptisch aufgrund der brutalen
entwicklung der kämpfe hier vor allem um
die stadt kiew wissen die leute nicht ob
sie putin wirklich trauen können aber
auf der anderen seite ist es natürlich
die einzige perspektive die hier im
moment im raum steht um diese kämpfe
relativ schnell zu beenden was ganz klar
ist die ukrainische bevölkerung und auch
die ukrainischen streitkräfte haben eine
relativ hohe moral im vergleich zu den
russischen streitkräften die hier im
land sind sie haben noch mal
international im prinzip rückendeckung
bekommen und präsident seelands sie hat
sich ja in dieser krise auch wirklich
als starke als starke führerfigur
entpuppt und den ukrainern ist es
wichtig dass ihr präsident das haben uns
alle mit denen wir auch heute hier
geredet haben an der regierung bleibt
also frieden mit russland ja das wollen
natürlich alle aber es ist die frage zu
welchem preis und der preis darf nicht
sein dass die ukraine ihre
selbständigkeit und ihre frei gewählte
regierung verliert was hören sie denn
über die momentane situation in der
hauptstadt kiew
wir haben mit einigen menschen in kiew
ihr kontakt und hören immer wieder wie
deren lage ist dass ich erzähl mal ein
beispiel eine junge mutter die zwei
kinder hat zwei söhne hat ein 10 und
einen vierjährigen sie selber ist im
vierten monat schwanger hat ihre eltern
noch in der wohnung und ihren mann und
kann im prinzip die stadt nicht
verlassen weil sie sagt sie möchte sich
natürlich nicht mit ihren eltern und
kleinen kindern auf den weg machen sie
haben sich komplett barrique agiert und
sie sagt sie hat große angst davor was
denn jetzt passiert wenn die stadt von
russischen truppen eingenommen wird sie
sagt wir berichten uns hier wirklich
darauf ein dass es hier einen längeren
belagerungszustand
gibt und dass möglicherweise auch
irgendwann es kein gas mehr gibt es
keine kein licht mehr gibt sie haben
sich mit lebensmitteln versorgt also
einfach große zukunft angst
zukunftsangst was bekommen sie denn
selbst von den russischen angriffe mit
welcher informationen bekommen sie
russland greift hier vor allem in hartz
iv also im osten der ukraine und in der
stadt kiew sehr sehr brutal durch aber
was sich zeigt ist dass die russisch
ukrainische bevölkerung doch dem
russischen militär vielmehr
entgegengesetzt als entgegensetzt als
mit dem die russen bisher gerechnet
haben was wir hören ist dass sich die
bevölkerung hier wirklich überall an
allen stellen selbst bewaffnet das
waffen ausgegeben werden dass die
menschen das haben wir auch schon in
beiträgen gehört sehr beim
molotow-cocktails bauen dass sie sachen
sammeln um soldaten zu unterstützen
also hier hat sich wirklich ein breiter
breiter widerstand zeigt sich hier der
ukraine und das haben sie natürlich auch
der tatsache zu verdanken dass sie hier
einen präsidenten haben der das volk
immer wieder motiviert dass auch die
bürgermeister der städte immer wieder
dazu aufrufen widerstand zu leisten
für die meisten ukraine entschuldigung
geht es hier um die zukunft ihres landes
und sie sind auch bereit dafür
einzutreten vielen dank katrin eigendorf
für diesen bericht aus der ukraine
ja und die zahl derer die aus der
ukraine fliehen reißt nicht ab über
300.000 sollen es inzwischen seien bei
der hypo ist in den äußersten osten der
slowakei gereist direkt an die grenze
zur ukraine
von dort sind es rund 250 kilometer nach
lemberg
angekommen nach tagen der flucht und
vielen stunden warten an der grenze es
ist erschöpfung und pure erleichterung
die sich da bahn bricht
nach den ersten bomben auf kiew haben je
länger und ihr sohn mischa die stadt
verlassen nach zwei tagen ohne schlaf
sind sie nun im auffanglager im
slowakischen
meine freunde meine familie mein mann
suchen schutz im keller oder in der
u-bahn denn die häuser werden
bombardiert
ich weiß von einigen babys mit dort nun
im untergrund geboren wurden
bei dem gedanken daran kann sie nicht
weiter reden
heute kam die slowakische präsidentin
caputo war und brachte hilfsgüter und
moralische unterstützung und 30.000
menschen sind bisher in die slowakei
geflohen
ist es da ein großer test für unsere
solidarität und menschlichkeit
im auffanglager bieten privatleute
kostenlosen transportmöglichkeiten noch
ist die hilfsbereitschaft groß doch es
ist klar es werden noch viel mehr
flüchten
anastassia wartet hier auf verwandte aus
nikolajew das wird gerade bombardiert
sie versteht die russen vor allem putin
nicht wir lieben doch eigentlich
einander bei den genossen ist da oben
doch etwas nicht in ordnung
es ist dann steht der strom der da über
die grenze kommt eine atempause ist es
hier für die meisten sie wollen weiter
gen westen
ja unsere situation der flüchtlinge gab
es heute auch ein treffen der eu
innenminister in brüssel anne gellinek
gab es dort auch eine zeitenwende
ja zumindest eine kurzfristige
zeitenwende denn wir haben hier heute
bei den eu-innenministern etwas
beobachtet was ist in brüssel schon
lange nicht mehr gegeben hat nämlich
eine mehrheit für die aufnahme von
flüchtlingen
das liegt natürlich auch daran dass jene
länder in osteuropa die sich bisher
strikt geweigert haben flüchtlinge
aufzunehmen das din und ausgerechnet die
sind die die meisten ukrainischen
flüchtlinge beherbergen und so ging
heute alles ganz schnell hier in brüssel
hat man eine richtlinie ausgegraben
wiederbelebt die man nach dem
jugoslawien krieg beschlossen hatte und
die 1 besonders schnelle und
unkomplizierte aufnahme von
kriegsflüchtlingen regeln soll
flüchtlinge dürfen bis zu einem jahr in
der eu ohne asylverfahren leben und
arbeiten mit meter geflüchteten
rechneten die eu
genaue zahlen gibt es nicht die
eu-innenkommissarin hat vorhin gesagt
300.000 seien bis jetzt in der eu
angekommen das uhren hcr rechnet mit
fünf millionen später hieß es 7
millionen das problem es ist weiß keiner
so genau weil sich auch viele
geflüchtete gar nicht melden bei
staatlichen behörden bis jetzt ist es
wohl so dass gerade in polen ganz viele
flüchtlinge direkt zu verwandten und
freunden gehen oder weiter reisen
innerhalb der eu ohne dass sie überhaupt
registriert werden die ukraine dürfen ja
visafrei nach europa einreisen vielen
dank anne gellinek
und wenn sie den menschen in der ukraine
helfen wollen können sie das tun beim
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
stichwort zdf nothilfe ukraine iban de
65 104 106 100 104 106 100 alle infos
auch unter spenden zdf de oder im zdf
text auf seite 8 190
angemeldet waren 20.000 menschen das
kamen weit über 100.000 die heute in
berlin gegen den russischen einmarsch in
die ukraine und für den frieden
demonstrierten
das motto stoppt den krieg frieden für
die ukraine und ganz europa henrik
henriette de maizière berichtet
mir frieden peace unter dem motto stoppt
den krieg frieden für die ukraine und
ganz europa haben sich heute an
verschiedenen orten berlins die menschen
versammelt ein bündnis aus
gewerkschaften kirchen und
friedensgruppen hatte zu einer
kundgebung an der siegessäule aufgerufen
die breite der zivilgesellschaft hat
gesagt dieser völkerrechtswidriger
angriffskrieg muss sofort aufhören und
wir müssen jetzt wirklich konsequenzen
daraus ziehen wir müssen diskutieren
über den importstopp für kohle öl und
gas wir dürfen nicht länger in
abhängigkeit von solchen despoten sein
die menschen hier sie wollen ihrer sorge
ausdruck verleihen solidarisch sein
um zeichen zu setzen die bowling folgen
gegen den verbrecherischen angriffskrieg
der russischen imperialisten und damit
bin total überrascht angeblich habe
keine tränen mehr
ich habe die ganzen augen ausgeweint
meine ganze familie ist da meine mutter
ist da die ganze verwandtschaft sind in
der ganzen ukraine zerstört
der
dämon mächtigen wunsch ausdruck zu geben
dass der krieg wieder aufhört und dass
wir nicht in einen noch schlimmeren
krieg rhein gestürzt werden wir werden
wahrscheinlich putin und sagen sie was
sie damit jetzt nicht aufwecken und wenn
wir können zeichen an unsere politik
sind wir können auch in die welt senden
es war ein großer tag der solidarität
mit der ukraine von tausenden menschen
auf die straße gebracht der wunsch nach
frieden eine forderung die bis vor
wenigen tagen doch noch so
selbstverständlich viel
erhoffen aufregend fragen wir dazu vögel
gar in moskau zurzeit finden ja
friedensverhandlungen zwischen russland
und der ukraine an der bille russischen
grenze statt was wissen sie dazu
also der start dieser verhandlungen der
hat sich verzögert und das liegt unter
anderem daran dass die ukrainische
delegation den weg zum verhandlungsort
ändern musste aus sicherheitsbedenken
diese vorsicht und auch dieses
misstrauen die ligen sicheren sicherlich
darin begründet dass man sich jetzt eben
doch im belarussischen grenzgebiet
trifft und billa russia eines der länder
ist oder dass ein land ist aus dem auch
die russischen truppen in die ukraine
eingedrungen sind aus dem aus russischer
raketen auf die ukraine abgefeuert
wurden präsidentielle hatte in den
letzten tagen immer wieder angeboten mit
russland ins gespräch zu kommen er hatte
ungefähr jeden anderen ort dafür in
betracht gezogen aussah belarus heute
ist er hatte also eingelenkt wenn die
gespräche dann losgehen dann bleibt er
die große frage worüber wird denn
überhaupt geredet ein russisches
delegationsmitglied hat gesagt man sei
eigentlich ziemlich kompromisslos was
die eigene position angeht
das würde dann bedeuten dass man
weiterhin darauf besteht die ukraine zu
entmilitarisierten und die region
auszutauschen das ist ja das was moskau
in seiner sehr eigenen sprachwahl immer
wieder gefordert hat in den letzten
tagen auf der anderen seite da steht
präsident selensky der sagt für ihn gehe
es darum die territoriale integrität der
ukraine wieder herzustellen die
verhandlungspositionen die scheinen also
denkbar weit auseinander zu liegen wie
ist denn überhaupt gerade der rückhalt
für den kriegskurs von wladimir putin in
der bevölkerung wächst der widerstand
also es gab auch heute wieder protest in
vielen verschiedenen russischen städten
und es gab auch wieder massive
festnahmen ca 2100 werden stand jetzt
aus dem ganzen land gemeldet das zeigt
wie gefährlich ist einfach ist offen
gegen den weg von wladimir putin auf die
straße zu gehen und so kann man davon
ausgehen dass auch wenn diese
demonstration jetzt erstmal zahlenmäßig
gar nicht so groß aussehen gemessen an
der einwohnerzahl von russland das ist
eben doch eine ganz große schweigende
bevölkerungszahl auch gibt die eben auch
gegen den krieg sind das wissen wir aus
vielen vielen gesprächen die wir in den
letzten tagen geführt haben und wo uns
leute gesagt haben sie haben angst vor
dem was jetzt in russland droht also zum
beispiel eben an der dass ihre
wirtschaftliche situation sich
verschlechtert dass sie ihre jobs
verlieren junge leute sagen sie haben
das gefühl sie werden hier um ihre
zukunft betrogen und viele haben auch
gesagt sie schämen sich für das was ihr
präsident da veranstaltet ob diese
menschen irgendwann sich ein herz fassen
und auch auf die straße gehen und ob das
dann wiederum den weg von wladimir putin
verändern wird das muss man abwarten
vielen dank für begann nach moskau
ja und das war unser zdf spezial an
einem wieder ereignisreichen tag
deutschland ändert seine außenpolitik
krieg flucht und leid in der ukraine
gehen weiter und sehr leise hoffnungen
liegen auf friedensverhandlungen
mehr dazu in einem heute journal und
danach auch in einer sonderausgabe von
maybrit illner zu gast dann auch die
außenministerin
baerbock auf wiedersehen
[Musik]